yesterday the Prime Minister suffered
the most devastating effete defeat in
Parliament on the most important issue
facing our country the central policy of
a government has been decisively
rejected the defeat that she suffered in
the vote on the European Union agreement
that she had reached was the biggest
ever defeat any government has ever
faced in British political history think
about that the biggest ever defeat on a
central plank of it it's clear that her
EU deal is now finished
they carry no question of tweaks or
sweeteners from Brussels to bring it
back to life the deal that she brought
back all the 500 plus pages of it is
quite clearly a dead deal she put it to
Parliament and it was emphatically
rejected and we now have to realise that
the Prime Minister seems completely
unable to grasp what has actually
happened she seems to be prepared to
send the country hurtling towards a
cliff edge to get a deal that can
command a majority in parliament Theresa
May has to ditch the red lines and get
serious about proposals for the future
last night's offer of talks with party
leaders turned out to be simply a stunt
not a serious attempt to engage with the
new reality that is needed no sooner had
she said the words in Parliament's than
the government confirmed that she would
not take no deal off the table so I say
to the Prime Minister again I'm quite
happy to talk but the starting point for
any talks about brexit must be that the
threat of a disastrous no deal outcome
is ruled out take it off the table and
we can talk about the future of the
plans that we will put forward and the
future relationship with Europe but take
no deal off the table now please Prime
Minister
[Applause]
and if she won't accept the will of
parliament to take no deal off the table
it will show that she simply isn't
serious about reaching a deal with no
deal on the table the Prime Minister
would enter into phony talks just to run
down the clock and try to blackmail MPs
to vote through her botched deal on a
second attempt by threatening the
country with the chaos that no deal
would bring if they resist her
entreaties to support her deal a second
time instead treasom a should show us
that she's serious about getting a deal
that Parliament supports and that brings
the country together by immediately
immediately ending the waste of hundreds
of millions of pounds of public money
preparing for a No Deal outcome which
simply cannot take place the government
[Applause]
the government has set aside 4.8 billion
pounds to prepare for No Deal there's so
many better things that money could be
spent on instead could support our cash
starved public services 4.8 billion
would pay for every two to four year old
to get free nursery education for a year
4.8 billion would help the crisis of
Social Care and funding in our NHS four
point eight billion would help the
crisis of rough sleeping homelessness
four point eight billion could do so
much for youth services in young people
around our country but no the government
is prepared to spend 4.8 billion of our
money on preparing for a No Deal brexit
in order to try and threaten MPs in to
voting for her deal which has already
been to clay declared bankrupt by
Parliament itself
Prime Minister take it off the table and
have a serious discussion about how we
approach the future
No Deal would risk huge damage to our
economy jobs and living standards about
that there is no doubt so labor is open
to discussions because we must end the
crisis caused by the government's
botched brexit negotiations and find a
solution that meets the needs of the
whole country
we the Labour Party have set out an
alternative plan and I've made clear we
would support a deal on that basis the
government may have survived a
confidence vote for now but we have a
government in name only the scale of the
defeat on Tuesday has shredded the last
vestiges of its authority if the
government had any confidence in itself
confidence in itself it would go back to
the people for a new mandate while
brexit consumes all the government's
energy the vital issues that affect
people most directly cash starved
schools the NHS at breaking point
rising bills unaffordable houses have
all gone to the back of the queue two
and a half years of brexit bundling of
and failure of left Parliament in
deadlock nothing can be deciding nothing
can get done we believe that the best
outcome for this crisis for the country
as a whole remains calling a general
election to break the deadlock and find
a solution that works for the whole
country
and that is why I tabled a motion of
no-confidence last night and I thank all
those colleagues that supported the
motion of no-confidence last night and
we will come back on it again if
necessary because we're determined to
deal with the issues facing this country
and also give the people a choice of who
their MPs should be and who their
government should be whether they have
one that stands up for them or one that
shows the degree of incompetence that
this government has shown but in the
meantime all options are on the table
we're serious about finding a way
through given the severity of the crisis
it'd be wrong to rule any of them out
our first option is the alternative plan
we've laid out over the past year labour
will put down its own amendments of the
bills next the proposals next week
setting out our alternative plan based
around a permanent customs union with
the European Union a strong single
market relationship and a guarantee at
least to keep pace with all EU rights at
work environmental protections and
consumer standards we will not take part
or allow this country to become part of
a race to the bottom in which the
poorest the most vulnerable lose out in
order to appease the very richest and
the biggest corporations in the world no
we want to see a protective protection
for the most vulnerable people in our
society
those three elements provide the
essential building blocks of a sensible
deal with the clear potential to win the
majority support in Parliament and I
believe such a deal would help to bring
people together and overcome the
divisions in our country but if the
government remains intransigent if
support for Labour's alternative is
blocked for party advantage and the
country is facing the potential disaster
of No Deal our duty will then be to look
at other options which we set out in our
conference motion including that of a
public vote
[Applause]
we we are in this position because the
Conservatives and other parties have
deliberately chosen to deepen divisions
setting those who voted leave against
those who voted to remain people voted
leave people voted remain but we are the
party that has consistently sought to
bring people together to find a way
through that respects people's concern
which ever way they voted in the
referendum because I believe the real
divide in our country is not between
leave and remain voters it's between the
many who do the work create the wealth
pay their taxes work in our society work
in our hospitals work in our schools
work in our factories deliver the
economy and the living standards for the
rest of us and those others those few
who break the rules or dodge their taxes
who run away and don't support our
society and our economy it's between the
many and the few labour set out in our
manifesto in 2017 the plans we have for
investment-led economy for good jobs for
a higher basic wage for an investment in
education in housing and health and all
those issues we set all that out because
we believe that's the direction in which
the majority of people in this country
want to go but on Tuesday while the
country's attention was fixed on
Westminster and the vote that took place
and it was a dramatic day in Parliament
I've never seen such chaos in any
government and I've been in Parliament
35 years and I've seen plenty of chaos
in government well that was the worst by
a long way we had yet another
demonstration of the harsh reality of
what this government about is about the
Department of Work and Pensions and the
MP for Hastings & rye is indeed the
Secretary of State for the Department of
working
pensions quietly decided to announce
another cut to Social Security which
according to analysis done by Age UK
could leave some couples up to seven
thousand pounds a year worse off their
latest cuts will force yet more people
onto the government's cruel Universal
Credit Scheme couples in which one
spouse is a pensioner will no longer be
entitled to pension credit so just
imagine this if you've paid into the
system all your life and you've retired
on a low income and now the government
decides you'll be poorer just because
your partner is younger than you that's
disgraceful
that's wrong and that was announced on
Tuesday while the rest of the nation was
watching Parliament and what was going
on there how typical of the Tories how
typical of amber Rudd whether they voted
leave or remain people want an end to
these in justices remember the vast vast
majority of people don't think of
themselves as remain errs or leavers
however they're regarded regarded by the
media as somehow or other a political
class that's got to be negotiated around
if we allow ourselves to be permanently
divided on these artificial lines it's
only the privileged elite that will
benefit while the majority lose out so
our message to the government is you've
lost your vote in Parliament you
survived yesterday on the loyalty the
rather thin loyalty of Tory MPs you and
we are determined to get a deal with the
European Union which as I've explained
sets out the three pillars that we will
put forward we are sensible we're
serious and we're positive about this
but our entire focus our entire focus
as a party is on the reality of people's
lives in this country the poverty the
insecurity the lack of investment the
concerns and fears for the future bring
people together to create that better
society and that better world have that
relationship with Europe that gives us
the Customs Union gives us the trade
protects the rights have that
relationship that is positive that is
open
I wanted have in a country that doesn't
rely on food banks that doesn't rely on
payday loans that doesn't rely on loan
sharks under live in a country where
people feel engaged enthused and
positive for the future that is the
Labour way and that will be the
forefront of our minds during the next
few weeks of crucial debate and voting
in Parliament deliver a society that
works for all not just a few